- So, hi everyone.
This is Priya Natarajan.
I am the current director
of the Franke Program
and I'm delighted to invite you all
to the discussion session that
follows our talk yesterday.
So yesterday we had as part of
our monthly colloquium series
in the understanding the
nature of inference project,
we had a talk titled
experiments for causal inference
and system identification
by professor Nihat Ay.
And as per custom, the day after the talk,
we have arranged to have
sort of a conversation
and a discussion between our speaker
and an invited interlocutor.
And I'm really thrilled that
the interlocutor we have today
to speak to professor Ay
is professor Kyle Cranmer
who is a physicist
as well as someone who
is at the cutting edge
of applying data science,
and machine learning
to understanding sort of the
complex physics data landscape.
His background is in particle
physics but I found...
For those of you who are interested,
we'll add a link to this.
In fact, Kyle is going
to be speaking later on
in our series as well
but he has a fabulous
paper that came out in PNAS
that really looks at the
question of inference
from simulations.
And I learned a lot from that work
and I'm really thrilled to
have the two of you converse.
So welcome Nihat, welcome
Kyle and take it away please.
- Great, thank you very much.
So, yeah, so I put together a few slides
just to kind of kickstart the discussion
and also in case anyone wasn't able to see
all of the talk yesterday.
So let me share those slides.
I won't drone on for too long.
And then we can get to
the more interesting part
of the discussion
- What a gorgeous graphic Kyle.
- Thank you.
Yeah, this is a collision event
at the Large Hadron Collider
where these very high
energy particles collide
in the center here
and all of these new
particles come flying out
into the detector.
And while it's a computer graphic,
it's a visualization
of an actual collision.
Ironically, it's with my
competitor experiment,
the CMS experiment while I
work on the ATLAS experiment
but they do have a good
graphics department
so (laughs) I'll take advantage of it.
So this is a conversation
with professor Nihat Ay.
And so first I'll just start by, you know,
showing his outline and the
kind of flyer that we had.
So again, this is part of this
multidisciplinary exploration
of the nature of inference,
correlation and causation.
I think it's a really
interesting a series of talks
that I'm very happy to be a part of it.
And so professor Ay really
talked about, you know,
really the core canon
around causal inference.
And so the outline was here.
We didn't get to everything
so some of these really
interesting things at the end
we didn't get to
but we did get to go through
kind of like a lot of the core
about to this idea of
identifiability of causal effects.
And I'm not going to repeat
everything thing that he said
but I will just kind
of rewind a little bit
and say that when we're talking
about inference, you know,
there's a lot of times the
way that I'm thinking of it
as a physicist, we have
very predictive models
and those predictive models
are tied to this idea
of mechanism.
And when we talk about causal
diagrams and things like this,
we're often talking
about mechanistic models.
And so it's really kind of
science in an old school way
where you really think you understand
what's going on underneath.
And so I think
that the theory is basically
having some parameters.
Here I called them theta.
And for me, they might
be things like the mass
of the Higgs particle
or the cosmological constant or something.
And I'm trying to use
that theory to predict
what I would expect the data to look like.
And oftentimes that's
done probabilistically.
I'm not saying the data
is gonna be exactly this,
it's a distribution for the data.
And then given some observed data,
I wanna turn it around and do inference
on the parameters data.
And there we go.
You see how inference
is kind of this inverse
of the predictive direction.
And oftentimes people refer
to these as inverse problems.
Now this is just kind of
Wikipedia level picture
of the scientific method.
Of course, you know,
inference in some sense
is just one piece of the scientific method
where we have some data in hand
and we're trying to infer
those parameters of the theory
for whatever experiment
or set of observations
we happen to have done.
Of course, the scientific
method is much more dynamic
where we're constantly
developing new hypotheses,
trying to figure out how to test them,
building new experiments.
So there's a lot more going on.
And so inference is really
kind of one particular aspect
of this process.
But the role of theory
also kind of contrast
against a lot of the
buzz that was happening,
I guess now it's been a few years.
This is a paper and
wired, I guess, from 2008
but when big data was like all the rage,
there was this idea
that big data was going to
make theory irrelevant, right?
And that the scientific
method would be obsolete.
And some of these ideas
were furthered by, you know,
and these ideas were
like the fourth paradigm.
There's a famous quote from Peter Norvig
at Google talking about, you know,
to riff off of his famous quote
that all models are wrong and saying,
"All models are wrong
and increasingly you can
get by without them."
And that's essentially saying
that if you have a lot of data,
maybe you just don't need them.
Okay, and so this very
much comes from a mentality
that certainly you would
see in something like Google
where your emphasis is largely
on prediction, you know,
given some data can I predict, you know,
someone's going to click on
an ad or something like that.
And now, so the kind
of counterpoint to that
has been, you know, led
largely by Judea Pearl
and, you know, many other people
but he is written for instance
a very well-known book
called "The book of Y"
and he's, you know, done a very good job
of communicating the deficiencies
in this kind of purely data-driven way
of going about things.
And he's described what he's
called the ladder of causation.
And so there's sort of
three different rungs
on this ladder, association, intervention
and counterfactuals
and professor Ay talked
a lot about intervention
and somehow kind of a
little bit the relationship
between these two.
I'll just say a little bit
more about association.
So association to me is largely
how I thought of statistics
prior to learning more
about causal inference
and the idea that you
have random variables
and you observe them and
there's a distribution for them.
And if you have many of them you want to,
for instance, understand
how they're correlated
and the best you could possibly do
is know the exactly the joint
distribution over some data.
And that would be maybe in the limit
of an infinite amount of data.
So you're not talking about big data,
you're talking about like
the idealized infinite
amount of data setting.
And what's become clear now
is that the types of questions
that you can answer with
data alone are restricted
and that there's a
broader class of questions
that you can address
but to answer them, you
have to include data
and some assumptions
and those assumptions
can come in various forms
but when you're talking
about causal inference,
it's usually comes in the form
of one of these causal graphs.
And so I think some people
maybe wouldn't necessarily want
to accept this at first
but the the nice part of what's happening
is you're getting just many examples
that make it kind of clear
that there's no way you're
gonna be able to answer
these questions.
So association--
- So Kyle if I may ask for clarification.
So when mention theories previously
does theory include simulations as well
like theoretical expectations
that are time evolved and so on?
Are you really talking about,
so if you take particle physics,
so if you're looking at
one of those collisions
as our sort of test case,
so would the theory be the standard model
and the expectations of all the particles
that you expect out of an interaction?
I wanna understand, like what
is the starting point there?
Can it be simulations?
The other is the simulation,
lattice gauge simulations,
for example, right?
So those are instantiations
of a theoretical prediction.
So do you make a
distinction between the two
or are you gonna lump them
into one thing as theory?
- Yeah, I think you could.
Yeah, and here, I guess
maybe the label here
is even kind of bad.
The theory in some sense,
these are really just the
parameters of the theory
on the far left.
To me I guess I would say
that simulation is oftentimes,
like you have a theory,
you may be able to write
it on a piece of paper
or something.
It's usually some kind of
maybe some platonic ideal
but the theory connected
with a concrete experimental scenario
or observational scenario
should be the thing
that allows you to make predictions
for what you think the
data will look like.
- Right.
- And so then the way that you actually go
about making the predictions,
there's details there, you know,
it might be a pencil
and paper calculation.
it might be a simulation
and that's an important part
and a lot of practical
issues arise in that.
But to me I guess, I think of the theory
as whatever it is that you need
to be able to make
predictions about the data
when coupled with a concrete observational
or experimental settings.
- So I mean the reason I ask is right
because if you look at
cosmology or astronomy
versus particle physics
one of the issues is the
particular epistemic role
of simulations themselves.
We cannot do any controlled
experiments in cosmology, right?
And in particle physics,
you are able to do these
controlled experiments.
So I was just very curious
whether these arrows
that you sort of nicely
sketched out for us,
they permit that flexibility
or is there something
different that happens
in a field when you can't replicate?
- Yeah, no, I think a lot happens there
and I didn't prepare
anything for that particular,
I mean, aspect of it and
let's see what you say.
I mean, in a more refined
version of this picture,
I would start to tease apart the theory
into pieces that are like the
parts you really care about
and then parts that describe
whatever else you need
to be able to make
predictions about the data.
So they may have to do
with your instrument.
They may have to do with
a lot of, for instance,
uncertain astrophysics that
you have no idea about.
And so that starts to
introduce these ideas
of like nuisance parameters
and things like this.
So to me in some sense
the way I'm using the word theory loosely
includes both the part
that you really care about
as a scientist and all
the other disinter oughta
that you need to include the,
make a prediction of the data.
And that part might be
highly uncertain, right?
And then difference about being able to do
repeated experiments
where you can actually kind
of control the circumstances
versus kind of a purely
observational setting
that's also going to have a huge influence
on what types of inference
you're going to be
and it's going to limit you.
I don't know that I would
separate that really
from how I think about
the theory per say--
- Okay.
- But there's a lot less
you can do (laughs).
And that touches a little bit
on the ideas of interventions
that we're getting to but--
- Okay, great.
No, I just wondered a
little bit of clarification
to understand if this
looping and the connection,
the way in which prediction
and inference themselves
are related, alters,
depending on if you have theories
that deal with data that
is not replicable, right?
So I was curious whether,
but it sounds like these arrows
and their directionality
remain as they are
but what you can infer
gets affected deeply
depending on, okay--
- Yeah, I think that's how
I would phrase it, you know,
and in terms of like at the higher level
not this inference task
but at the higher level
like this kind of
scientific method approach.
If you're able to repeat experiments
or change circumstances
obviously you're gonna
have a much more powerful
set of tools available to you
but that already kind of
points at what's going on
a little bit as if you think
of it at the association level
is largely kind of this picture.
You have data and you're kind of like
if a theory gives you a joint
distribution on the data
then you know everything
that there is to know
and some sense there's
nothing more to the story.
And if you had like an
infinite amount of data
then like it should just reduce
to mathematics and calculus.
It's not much more to the story
but we somehow as scientists,
we know there's a lot more to the story
and your example about observational
versus controlled experiments
points to the fact
that they're different.
But somehow that difference is not lying
just in this picture.
It's lying in the broader
setting of what can we do
as scientists and yeah.
- Great thanks for the clarification.
- No, it's a great question
and something that we could
talk about for hours and hours.
So I don't wanna go on too long
but I do wanna motivate a little bit more
so this was kind of the big
data, early machine learning
and also a lot of the data science
and machine learning narratives
have been about, you know,
around this kind of idea
that maybe data can solve
all of our problems.
And so, yeah, and as I mentioned
in this ladder of causality
that a lot of that
thinking is really stuck
at the lowest rung here of association
and that there kinds of questions
you're basically just not
going to be able to answer
and there's a broader set of questions
that you're going to be able to address
but they are going to kind
of require assumptions
and those assumptions are usually encoded
in the like a graphical
or a causal model, right?
And so, okay, so just zooming in
on kind of what kinds of
questions you're asking.
And so associations are largely like
if I knew X how does it
change my belief in Y?
And those are things kind of
like conditional distributions
and a lot of prediction
tasks can be cast this way
but intervention is
asking a kind of question
like what if I do something,
what's going to happen?
So the example here is
if I take an aspirin
will my headache be cured?
You know, and like what will happen
if you make a policy change
or something like that?
And it could be something like, you know,
I don't know what will happen
if I point my telescope
in the side of the sky
or what will happen if I change the energy
of the beams colliding at
the Large Hadron Collider,
things like this.
And so you're going in
and you're intervening
and you're doing something.
And counterfactuals are
kind of another level
that are very similar
but the main difference here
is that you're not necessarily able to go
make that intervention
like an examples that gave before,
I can decide to take the aspirin or not.
Here's an example that's like
if I had taken an aspirin,
would it have stopped my headache?
And it sounds like it's just a grammar
but the fact that it's
represented in our grammars
shows how important it is, right?
These are things that I can't do.
I can't actually make this intervention.
So how will you answer
a question like this
is more difficult
and it's a little bit
tied to like imagination.
You're not going to actually collect data
under these circumstances.
You're going to have to
kind of imagine them.
And that imagination does
kind of make you think
about simulations a bit as well, right?
So if you have a causal model,
you can kind of start to
probe these sorts of questions
but what you're gonna be able to do
with actual data is gonna be restricted.
And so then just to kind of
close the loop a little bit
is if you look at thought leaders
and for instance, deep learning,
I mean, machine learning
like Yoshua Bengio, you know,
they're looking at like
what are the bottlenecks
for things like deep learning.
It's not that they don't have enough data
but you have things
like you're a classifier
of if it's a cat or a dog
or you're a automatic
driving car system might,
you train it and it might work pretty well
but then when you apply
it to real world images
or real world data, it
might not perform well.
And that might be because
that's what's sometimes referred
to as a domain shift, okay?
And so the question
is if a lot of the machine learning things
that just take advantage of correlations
if you change the
distribution a little bit,
they may behave in a way
that you don't want them to.
And so the claim here is like, okay,
well, what if we like structure
our machine learning things
so that they have some causal mechanism
and if we've got it
right then the hypothesis
is that basically it's
gonna take less data
and you're gonna be more robust
and have all these great
things that people care about.
And these are the things that are kind of
on the way to something more
like artificial intelligence
than just kind of a curve fitting picture
of machine learning.
So with that like a
little intro professor,
I basically walked us through
a lot of the technology
about how this works.
Showed us graphical models.
These Bayesian networks gave
us a mathematical formalism
and introduced a lot of
the really core concepts.
One of the points that he raised
and I think this is one of the things
that's really important
is that when you think
about a data distribution,
there's sort of two ways to think of it.
One is to think of it as just
a big joint distribution,
this kind of agnostic about
how the data got there.
And the other way is to think
of a data generating process right?
So it can literally be time
or it can be some abstraction of that
but you have something
that's producing the data.
And what's interesting
is that here are three
different causal diagrams
that all tell a different story
about how the data got there
and they may have the
same joint distribution
but the story, the narrative,
the mechanism is different
in the different cases.
And so the question is how
can I sort of tell them apart
if ultimately I care about this mechanism?
And so here I think a toy
example, it can be super useful.
So took it from this blog
post which is really nice.
And it's just making two-dimensional data.
And I don't wanna scare
you with the programming
but hopefully this is like simple enough
that you have a random variable X
and then you calculate a new variable Y
and there's three different
various simple programs
that make variables X and Y.
And what's interesting is
they all give you exactly
the same joint distribution.
So from the point of view of
association, they're identical
but they have three different stories
about how you get there.
And you might think, well, who cares,
these are just like different
ways to make the data
but they correspond to
different graphical models
and these directed ones so
they have a causal story.
And then professor, I
went through these ideas
of the do-calculus and
interventions and the do-operation
and tried to explain to us
like why that's different
than just simply conditioning
and then also show
that while you might be very
difficult to actually do
those interventions,
if you know something about this graph,
you can kind of predict what would happen
if you do an intervention.
And it's exactly the fact
that there are two different strategies.
One which is actually
doing the intervention
and seeing what happens
and the other is that
you think you can predict
what would happen
if you know the underlying causal graph.
That's kind of the important part, right?
And so that's what you see here
is that in some of these
equations on the left,
you see for instance, the do operation
and on the right you see things
that are look more like
conditional distributions
and things like this put
together in various ways.
And so he went through a few
different examples of this
and I'm not gonna go
through through all of that,
just kind of reminding some plots.
But in this toy example,
what's interesting
and this also ties into simulations
is that the way that you
can think about intervention
is that okay, I'm going to
generate this random variable X
and what I want to do is
understand the intervention
where I set X equal to three.
So that's this do operation.
I'm gonna set X equal
to three to intervene,
sort of like I'm gonna force
the person to take the aspirin.
And what you would think of is like, okay,
you generate the random X.
Like I decide that maybe I
don't wanna take the aspirin
but I'm gonna intervene
and say, no, you are
taking the aspirin, right?
So you're setting X equal to three.
And then basically in
every step of the program,
you're just gonna make
sure X is equal to three.
And if you do that then the
distribution that you get out,
you know, X is gonna be equal to three,
no surprise there
but the interesting part
is the distribution for Y
is not the same in these different cases.
And that's the statement
that the intervention,
the do operation is not
the same as conditioning.
And here you see it just
in a very explicit example.
But this is a very simple one.
And the question is how
do you scale this up?
And this is where professor
Ay's research is really focused
is all of these wonderful theorems
that kind of talk about how to extend this
even to very complicated situations.
And I won't say more,
I won't say this about counterfactuals.
He did give some nice examples
about these like front door
and back door examples.
Gave examples in the context of robotics
and artificial life.
This example made me think of some work
that I'd seen from DeepMind
on reinforcement learning.
In reinforcement learning
they have like an agent,
for instance, trying to explore some world
that looks like a an
Atari game or something.
And they had an example
where the training data
is the way that the
reinforcement learning algorithms
are usually trained is
at the association level.
And it makes a mistake.
And they tried to come in
and fix that mistake through
this backdoor adjustment
which is very much like what we see here.
So this is just to kind of reinforce
that these ideas of causal inference
are really at the cutting edge
of like way that people are thinking
about moving machine learning
kind of from where it was
with its first era of big
data and supervise learning
and deep learning to
something a little bit more
towards artificial
intelligence which is going,
I think increasingly recognize
that causal inference is gonna
be a major part of the story.
So that was my little intro.
I apologize if that went on too long.
And so I'll stop there.
And maybe the first question
is just to ask professor Ay
if I completely butchered this story
or if it seemed like a
reasonable compliments
to what you presented to
us yesterday (laughs).
- So thank you so much.
That was a great summary
and the extension of what
I have presented yesterday.
So actually I had the feeling
yesterday that my presentation
was a little bit technical
and my intention was to
begin this conversation
with a kind of intuitive explanation
of what I talked about yesterday
but you already gave that overview.
So you summarized the main
points of my presentation
in a very clean and
intuitive and nice way.
So thank you so much for that.
So you highlighted the main
components of the theory
or the main messages that I intended
to actually tell yesterday
but you're also, actually,
the beginning of your presentation
is related to this data science idea.
It's very interesting.
So when you do in the context
of a generative model,
so you have a neural network
and the intention often is to...
So you have the data
coming from the world.
Okay, and let's talk about the sensors.
So you have the sensors
and you have some joint
distribution generated by the world.
Okay, and you try to intrinsically
provide some explanation
for that.
The generative neural network
let's say it's layout deep neural network
and it's trained in a way
that it can actually explain the data.
So it can generate the same distribution
as the distribution
generated by the world.
And then the question is
to what extent can we...
So on both sides of the sensors,
so the world and the the neural
network can be represented
in terms of a causal network.
So neural network is a special
kind of causal network.
And then there is a causal
network of the world
that is generating the data.
And we should not confuse
and I think you implicitly
made that statement.
We should not confuse the causal network,
our ability to generate
the data from inside
in terms of the neural network
with the understanding of the
underlying causal structure
of the world.
So knowing that your network,
the causal structure of the neural network
does not tell us anything
about the causal structure
of the world.
So both of them are able to
generate the same distribution
on the periphery so to say.
And that's an interesting point.
So that shouldn't be confuse.
So if I'm able to
actually predict the data
there might be many, many
possible solutions to that.
And I think the world is one solution
but the network itself
is also one solution.
The theorem that I presented
at the end of my talk yesterday
basically tells us what kind
of structural requirements
we need in order to be able
to generate that distribution.
- Right?
- So if the generated
distribution has high redundancy,
let's say a particular kind of redundancy
that cannot be generated by any network.
So it does tell us put some
constraints on both sides
so to say off the periphery
- Right.
So Nihat had a quick question here.
So I mean, the question often
when we're dealing with
the kinds of data sets
that we are dealing with
say, while modeling, right?
Is the discrimination
between the solutions.
And so one advantage in physics.
So as I was talking about yesterday
working on the black hole
growth problem or whatever.
So you actually have physical principles
that are going to constrain the world,
sort of the map of
solutions that are offered.
So some of them are
going to be unphysical,
some of them are not going
to tally with cemeteries
that physics, the underlying
fundamental physics.
So do you think that
this inference process
deeply depends on the
kind of data that we have
and the relationship between the world
and the neural network that
is getting the information
from the world?
Because in fields like physics,
we know there are these principles, right?
That constraint and restraint.
So what is the role?
I mean, do you see physical
laws as do functions
or are they...
What are they?
- So that's a very important point.
So I introduce the notion of a mechanism
which is basically mark of counter
but that can be any mark of counter.
So I did not provide any
justification of a part,
any distinction between physical
and nonphysical Mark of counter.
So all of them can be
realized in terms of physics
but so observationally, let's
take the most simple case.
You have X and Y
and you have an arrow from X to Y.
Observation you cannot
distinguish this from an arrow
from Y to X.
Okay, but if you compute
the condition distribution
of Y given X and the condition
distribution of X given Y,
you might have additional
information coming from physics
which tells you that
one of these directions
cannot be actually considered
as being physically plausible.
That is an additional information
that I did not incorporate
into my analysis yesterday
but it plays an important role.
So it could be for example,
that you have a whole set of
observationally equivalent,
mark of equivalent graphs
but only some of them are
physically justifiable.
- Right.
- And that is actually
the basis of the group
in Tübingen around Baden-Württemberg
who basically say we have
to understand the primitive
so to say, this X, Y example.
And they basically argue
that the right direction
has to have low complexity.
So physics prefers low complexity.
So you compute the P of Y
given X and the P of X given Y
and then you can consider,
take for example,
the mark of counter and
the commingle of complexity
of that mark of that
counter of both of them
and then you prefer the
one that has the smaller
commingle of complexity.
- And the criterion
is that the smaller
commingle of complexity--
- Complexity that, that would reflect
the more physical directions.
And that, of course, as you
say it's a further argument
in order to be able to distinguish
between observationally equivalent graphs.
So I don't think that they
provide a physical argument
but I think it's an important direction.
So commingle of complexity
might not be the right quantity
to take but I think the argument
may be related to something
like the second law of thermodynamics--
- I was just gonna say,
it sounds like entropy--
- Yeah, so that would
allow you to actually
distinguish further
but that's a whole new argument
that I did not talk about yesterday.
- Right.
Kyle, did you want to weigh in on this.
- Yeah, I mean, well, the notion
of it being low complexity
in some notion of complexity,
I think is just a very natural version
that's something like Occam's razor
or minimum description length.
It's like it has many, many forms
and it's somewhat natural that, you know,
it's basically just saying
if the fundamental mechanisms
are simple.
It gets a little complicated
and that you might have very
simple fundamental mechanism
but if you're not observing
at that granularity
then the aggregate effect of that
is could be some super complicated thing.
And so then it's not clear
that the right causal arrow
and the wrong causal arrow
is gonna manifest itself
in terms of some complexity measure
if you're not seeing like
the actual mechanism.
But that's its own, that's a
very interesting discussion.
One thing that I was going
to say and in my own kind of
is I started going down the
rabbit hole of causal inference
is just trying to understand
at a very, you know,
almost like sociological
level as me as a physicist,
how is it that I don't know
about causal inference?
You know, the term causality is baked
into being a physicist.
And also so many of the
examples that you see,
people go back to thinking
about physical examples
or, you know, and talk about scientists.
And so I was trying to reconcile,
how is it that this thing
that seems to be so important
for the scientific method
and so closely related
to being a physicist
is something that from a
mathematical point of view,
don't feel, you know, it's not familiar?
I was never taught about causal inferences
in my physics classes.
And so I think part of
that is that, you know,
well, where I landed
on that is two things.
One is that we take it
for almost for granted
and it is so much a part of our thinking
and it is very much a
part of why physicists
have been successful.
You know, if you think about
the scientific processes
like the language of AI,
we've had almost no data
and almost no compute for the
history of human civilization
to have learned so much about
how the universe works, right?
And the only way that we got there
was not through deep
learning or something, right?
It was through exploiting causal structure
and assumptions about causal structures.
I might totally, you know, convinced
that the only way that
we got to where we are
is by exploiting that over
and over and over again.
So it seems to me very important
at the same time I don't
know about this language.
I'm learning but like I
didn't know about the language
of the do-calculus and stuff.
And so why is that?
And I think it's partially
because of the causal structure
in so many physics problems is obvious.
it's might be very uncertain components
but I know that whatever happened
in the star happened first
in like the it on the way through the dust
and the galaxy happened next
and then through the atmosphere was next
and then the telescope and
then my data analysis pipeline.
The causal structure is
usually really obvious.
And when you get into
situations like medicine
or social sciences and things like this,
the causal structure is far from obvious.
You know, you have no
idea what's doing what
and people disagree.
And so there in order to make progress,
you really had to develop the calculus
to be able to manipulate these things
which like they're very counterintuitive
a lot of times right?
Even though--
- You needed a very formal description.
Yeah, yeah, you've sort
of really nailed it.
I think in physics it's a
lot more intuitive in a way
but for these other disciplines,
you need to sort of
formalize the structure
and order it, right?
And order it.
As you said, one of the interesting things
in the example that you gave,
I mean, there is never ambiguity.
It is never a question that
once the photons are released
all the filters through
which they have to go through
to reach us, right?
And the fact what follows what
is a pretty patternly clear, right?
- Yeah, I think so.
And then, yeah, so I think
that part's interesting.
I can say there are a few other things
from a physics point of view
that they become interesting
for causal inference.
So one of them I'll just mention
is that if you think about
something like thermodynamics
and equilibrium,
that's a situation we're like
you have like the ideal gas
law, like pressure and volume
and the temperature,
you know, PV equals nRT.
And it's just an equation.
And so many things in physics
are written as equations,
E equals MC squared.
You know, they're all there
and there's no causal direction there.
And I don't just mean in the deeper sense
that like our first talk about
kind of the arrow of time
but I just mean it's
just an equality, right?
And so I think it's interesting
because A, I think a lot of
times when we write equations
like that, we're basically
making a mistake.
When we write those equations,
we really mean something
like the inferred value
from these other things are equal
and like almost like a
maximum likelihood sense.
But the other part is that the...
And something like, you
know, if you push down
on the piston and the volume goes down
and the temperature goes up,
like who's causing what.
And it's pretty clear
you're pushing on it, right?
But in other cases like I heat it up
and then the piston goes up, right?
It's the same relationship
but the causal story goes kind
of in a different direction.
And what's a little
interesting to me there
is that it goes back to the first talk.
If you think about core screenings
and macroscopic structure
versus microscopic structure, you know,
a lot of the way that
that first seminar was,
was we see causality and the macroscopic
but when you go to the micro, sorry,
you see causality and
the macroscopic world
but when you go to the microscopic world,
it goes away cause you have
the time reversible dynamics
but the equilibrium one is a
little bit the opposite story.
The macroscopic story is
kind of not really clear
what the causal thing is cause
you're always in equilibrium
and there's no real causal
graph that's obvious.
But if you could zoom in
and see like the atoms bouncing around
or something like that, you know,
at some mesoscopic course grading
you would see like which way, you know,
who's causing what, right?
You know, you're out of
equilibrium for a little bit
and you know what's happening.
So I think that part as a
physicist is kind of interesting.
And then the other
question is like, you know,
in the do-calculus,
what if I wanted to like intervene
and set like the energy
of a particle to something
without modifying its momentum, right?
If I did that, like I would break the laws
that say how energy and
momentum are related,
the on-shell conditions.
So there are a lot of
interventions that don't, you know,
if I had a simulator in principal,
I could go in there and
change those numbers
but they don't make any sense physically.
So in addition to the causal
arrows maybe being physical
or not, some interventions
don't seem realizable.
And so I'm not part of the discussion.
I don't know much about it.
But I know there's a lot of
like philosophical debates
about interventions in the do-calculus.
And what does it mean
if you can't actually
make that intervention?
So I'd be curious to
hear a professor Ay talk
about that a little bit
cause I don't really know about it.
- Yeah, so that's a
very interesting subject
and I don't think it's fully resolved.
So there is, of course, in physics,
not only directed in interaction
but also on undirected
like the Ising model,
you have undirected interactions.
And so that's one thing
I didn't talk about that.
There is some work trying
to actually explain
undirected interactions
in terms of many, many, many direct
and indirect interactions.
So like integrated phenomenon so to say.
But the theory is not--
- It's not settled, right?
The question is not settled.
- It's not settled.
So that's one thing, it's not settled.
But then there's also physical constraints
which is maybe special case
of functional constraints.
So you cannot change one variable
without changing the other one.
And that's exactly the problem that we had
in the context of robotics.
So we have really constraints,
physical constraints
and physical constraints
imply that many configurations
have zero probability.
Okay, and this is why you
cannot actually compute
the conditional distribution.
And as I said yesterday, so
this identifiability problem
really requires strict positivity
of the joint distribution.
And when you have these
physical constraints,
you don't have this strict positivity
so they don't hold anymore.
This identifiability equations
that I presented yesterday.
So it's a limitation of
the theory, I would say.
- Yeah, I mean, going back
to Colonel Bradley's talk
in the first one.
He also made this point about agency
and I sort of like going
in and changing things.
And I think, if you go all
the way down the rabbit hole
of thinking about fundamental physics
and things being time
reversible and et cetera,
it almost turns into the point
that basically none of the interventions
are gonna be possible
because everything is so tied together
that you can't move one thing without...
And so it seems like it points to,
at the end of the road,
that you're not going to really be able
to do such an intervention
unless you can only consider a subsystem.
And that was exactly I think his point
is that if you consider it a subsystem,
so you can change something internally
and something externally
has to react for consistency
then you start seeing those
kinds of interventions
and a lot of ideas about
causality start to emerge
and that can be somewhat
of the resolution.
- I think he also briefly
alluded to the fact
that or if you could make a complete map
of all interferences
like all the existing correlates
between variables, right?
So cause when he was trying
to contrast the quantum case
from sort of classical cases,
he was saying, well, you
know, the classical case,
you can actually map out what
all changes deterministically
when you change one thing
but as in quantum mechanics
that itself is not often well-defined.
So yeah.
So yeah
- One point I also wanted to comment
on this notion of agency.
I think that was not highlighted
in the previous talk.
So when you do intervention,
it is really important that the
intervention is independent.
So the agent who is
intervening is independent
of the system, statistically independent,
otherwise you don't get the
results that I have presented.
So intervention really has to assume
an agent sitting outside
and really deciding on
the state to intervene.
So that sets some constraints on agency.
On the other hand, the
creatures that we studied
in this robotic setting,
these are agents, so there's agency
but these agents really,
before they act they
receive some information
from the environment through
their sensors and then they act
and that's a kind of a
disconnect with the theory.
So our agents are--
- But don't they have a
set of formal instructions
already specified if they sense X,
they can do Y1, Y2 or Y3.
It's finite.
If they sense Z, they can
do three possibilities.
So I mean, how is that independent?
Because they are already
instructed, right?
I mean, there's a--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that's, that's what I'm saying.
They are not independent.
- Okay.
- And we call them agents and
they would not be qualified
this way of lookup table
of which action to choose
based on which sensory input
would not be consistent
with the notion of intervention
that I talked about yesterday.
Yeah so...
- Yeah, probably some fine
grained language there
is it necessary (laughs)?
- Yeah
- Yeah, I think at this point
we can open up to questions.
If there are any questions
from the audience
please feel free to indicate in the chat
that you want to ask the
question and we can unmute you
- So may I also suggest.
So one thing, I wanted to actually try
to draw a little bit the kind of reasoning
that I presented yesterday
maybe as a starting point
for further questions or discussion.
- That'd be great.
- So let me try to connect my iPad.
- Yeah.
- It's a modification of the
diagram that we just saw.
(all laugh)
Okay, so basically what I wanted to show,
so we have this diagram here.
- Oh, this is wonderful.
I was just saying, we miss a blackboard.
So this is great.
- Yeah, so we had this
prediction and this is the data.
This is the theory.
And then we had inference.
So before I saw this diagram,
I actually prepared another one
in order to illustrate what
I have presented yesterday.
So basically we have a system.
And we want to understand that system,
the inner working of that system.
So we do experiments and these
experiments generate data.
And with the data, we can
actually do the inference,
like we denote this by question mark.
So that's the general paradigm.
So I think it was referred
to as the inverse problem,
inference as the inverse
problem from the data.
And now the question is
what kind of experiments?
So now I'm going to
specialize this a little bit.
So the system was bottled in
terms of a causal network.
And then I presented yesterday
three kinds of experiments.
One is simply observation and
this creates one type of data.
Let's call it data one
and you can ask the
question what can I get
from just observing the system?
So that's one way to do experiments.
The second one is intervention
and that generates a second kind of data.
And you can ask the same question.
And the thing that I had
no time to talk about it
is sometimes you do
experiments, for example,
in the context of genotype,
phenotype mapping,
you do knockout experiments.
You'll knock out genes
in order to understand
the function of the gene.
And that's some kind of intervention
but basically it's a kind
of structural intervention.
You remove parts of the system
to see the role of the gene,
you remove the gene or block the gene.
And then if you see an effect,
a change of the phenotype
you say, ah, that gene was
responsible for this phenotype.
And that was what I wanted
to talk about yesterday.
So that's a knockout.
- So Nihat here I want you to clarify,
so these cosmological
simulations that we do.
So I want both of you to clarify for me
which kind of interventions are there?
Because I can see them
being a normal intervention
or a knockout because I
can choose parameters.
There are a few numbers that
characterize a typical universe
and then you can evolve them.
And I can choose a
different set of parameters
and evolve different universes.
So in that sense, it's knockout
because I can by hand fix values
but then is it an intervention
or is it a knockout?
- I think a knock out
would be maybe more like
if you were trying to
understand, you know,
say how black hole, I mean,
black dark matters, sorry,
dark matter clumps in the universe
and the role of like gas and
geons and stuff like that.
If you just took out the gas
and re-ran the simulation
that's sort of like
removing a whole mechanism
that seems to closer to a knockout to me.
The other one where you're
just running the simulation
with different values of the parameters.
To me that's a, well, I mean,
it's sort of making a
prediction for different values
of the parameters of the theory.
If you want it, you can
think of that as a--
- Intervention.
- Well, yeah.
And then there's a
question is in intervention
or is it like just conditioning?
But usually those
parameters are at the top
of the causal model, right?
And if I, professor, I can, correct me
but one of the examples he gave
if you intervene at the thing,
that's the very apparent then conditioning
and interventions are the same.
So then there's no distinction.
- Yeah, I think that's what I got too.
Is that right Nihat?
- Yes, I wouldn't say so, yeah.
- Okay, but then if I change the nature
of dark matter itself would that be...
- Yeah, I think there you get
into a question of when
you think about theories
do you think of them as
like continuous parameters
and if you have two different theories
it's like a discrete choice,
you can either think of them
as two different theories
or you can think of it as one theory
with like a discreet parameter.
But like to me, the structure of inference
and conditioning and
do-operations aren't changed.
- Have not changed, okay?
- It's more about discrete and continuous.
- Okay.
- So maybe we can move to
the questions (giggles).
- Yeah, no, but this was really nice,
the clarification of
the three kinds of ways
of generating data and
therefore the inference loops.
So to finish up, you were saying that...
So your argument is that
the way inference works
in these three kinds of
causal systems is different.
- So my argument is that in order
to reveal the inner working of the system,
you can't just observe it,
you need to apply different
kinds of experiments.
And I got into this actually when I went
to the Santa Fe Institute as a post-doc
and there I met Jessica Flack
who was studying primate societies
and she was actually liking
the gene knockout experiment.
She was actually removing
some of these individuals
from the society and recording the changes
of the behavior in that society
in order to understand the
role of that individual
in the society.
So that was very interesting.
So the idea, again, I
remove structurally parts
of the system and then see what happens
in order to understand the function.
And that's exactly like the idea
that underlies gene knockouts.
But I was puzzled by this
whether we really have a
philosophical or conceptual basis
for this approach.
Of course, the idea is
if I remove something
and the behavior changes
or the phenotype changes
then I understand the function.
That's basically the
idea but I was not sure
whether there's some
conceptual foundation of it.
And then I try to understand it
in terms of Judea
Pearl's causality theory.
And it seems to me that we
need more than intervention.
We really structural
perturbation of the system,
removal of parts, for
example, neurons in the brain
really revealed some additional
information about the system
that we cannot get simply by intervention.
And this is why--
- Yeah, and the interesting thing
is that if I'm understanding it correctly
that this knockout is not
actually loss of information.
It is loss of a particular
kind of information
that is going to be richer
in terms of what it gives you for data.
- Exactly, exactly, exactly, yeah.
- Yeah, and I think this
last part maybe is that...
So I agree about this kind of
complimentary set of diagrams
with the different types of
experiments that are being done.
And I think if you can go
back to the scientific method
part of it, what's interesting
is that when people try to
decide what experiment to do,
you know, part of it is
about trying to come up
with like the one that has
the most statistical power
within some kind of just
at the association level
but there's also a lot of
times a good experiments
are kind of what reveal, would
be able to break a degeneracy
between say two competing
mechanisms, right?
So you have like two hypotheses
for what the graphical
model might look like.
They're both consistent
with the data that you have thus far.
And you're trying to build one
that's going to try to like
make a sharp distinction
between those two.
And figuring out how to
design them, you know,
a lot of times you can
just inspect the graph
and kind of if you know a little
bit about what's going on,
you have a pretty good idea
of what you should go do.
And that's largely how
experimentalists have done things
or just through intuition, you know,
like, oh, well if I do this,
that's gonna happen, you know?
And so that's pretty miraculous.
And if you contrast that against something
like reinforcement learning
where you just like drive
the car off the cliff
a million times until it's a
really good race car driver
or something.
They're very differential, right?
But then the other part of that,
the other side of that coin
is if you do an intervention
and you get some data
and it doesn't conform
to what you expect in your causal model,
maybe any of them then you're
like what's going wrong.
And like I can exclude that theory
but that's not the end
of the story, right?
You then start generating new hypotheses
and you start trying to figure out
like what is the new mechanism
that could potentially
respond in the way that I saw.
And again that imagination
and the hypothesis building
is not at the level
of like running a lot
more low-level simulations
it's at this very like
high-level, you know,
big building block course grand picture
of what's going on.
And yeah, so again I think it's a place
where you see like that's super
core to how we think about,
like children playing.
It's all about that.
I pushed the thing off the
table a thousand times and yeah.
So that interplay is
really interesting to me.
- Right.
And then I think also
in the cases of building
these kinds of physical
models driven by physics,
I mean, those are the
places Kyle as you mentioned
where it could be revealed
that you actually have
picked the wrong variables.
You know, these are not the
characteristic variables
that actually are salient to
the dynamics of the system
or to predict behavior, right?
So I think sometimes you get stuck in that
where you suddenly do realize
that when none of the causal
networks actually works
to explain the data
that perhaps what you have actually chosen
to generate the data are not
the right variables, right?
And they don't actually
capture all the features
of the model.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, the other thing
I like about that picture
is when you think about
reductionism and emergence
and things like this, you
can kind of think of them
as different causal models
at different scales of that.
You're thinking about a system
and maybe they're all connected
but the way the phenomenon
manifest themselves
look drastically different, right?
At the different scales.
And ultimately if you could
somehow understand the mapping
between like the more the
reductionist causal model
and the emergent one,
like that's a fantastic
if you can do that.
And very occasionally we
can do things like that
with like quarks and gluons
to protons to atoms and molecules.
And like occasionally
we can make that bridge
but if we could get a lot better at that
and I think that's what
the kind of significance
of a lot of this machinery is,
it's like kind of the necessary
step towards that path.
- I think we can probably conversing,
let me quickly check in
if anyone has questions.
Please don't feel shy and
just type the question in
and, you know, any kind of question is...
We are totally open.
So don't feel like you
have to ask a question
or a comment that is highly impressive.
So I think Rob Comans has a question
who said that I still need to dive
into professor Ay's work here
but do you have any comments
on causal information theory?
Is this field well developed
or are there good reasons
that information theory
is less useful
or relevant with
interventional distributions?
- So that's a very good question.
So I think they are tightly
coupled the two theories.
So originally when information
theory was invented
by Claude Shannon, he
considered actually channel.
Channel, that's the term
for a mark of counter
or the stochastic map.
So that's the mechanism.
So he did consider mechanisms.
But it was a very simple
setting, sender and receiver.
Okay, so you have X and Y
and then you have the arrow
between them and you can
compute the mutual information.
The fundamental quantity there
is the mutual information.
And the mutual information is a kind of
or mutual information rate
is a kind of a measure
for the information flow from X to Y.
Now, if you have the situation
that Kyle was referring to
where you have a common cause.
Let's say you have X, Y
but they are influenced by Z, okay?
And there is no cause information flow
from X to Y but they are correlated.
So if you compute the mutual
information between X and Y,
you will get a positive quantity
but you would then assume, okay,
there is information flow
from X to Y which is wrong.
Okay, but then the way we
correct this is the following.
We say, okay, instead of
measuring the joint distribution
of X and Y by just observing it,
we have to intervene in X and observe Y.
And then you do this in the context
of this common cause example,
so Z is acting on X and Y.
You intervene in X and the
condition distribution of Y
given X is simply the distribution of Y
because it does not depend on X anymore
and the reason is that there
is no arrow from X to Y.
So if you do the
interventional conditioning,
you get the mark of counter,
a channel that has no
information flow from X to Y.
And if you then, after
intervening in this,
after changing the notion of conditioning
then use information theory
then you get the real notion
of causal information flow.
So combining the notion of intervention
with classical information
theory gives you a nice formalism
to quantify cause and information flows.
And this is what I did together
with Daniel Polanyi actually.
I hope this answers the question
- That was a really clear and wonderful.
Anyone else?
Any other questions?
So before we conclude,
Kyle did you have any final questions?
Did you...
- No, no I think it's been
a fascinating discussion
and I appreciate being
a part of it (laughs).
- Thank you very much.
So thanks Nihat and thank you
Kyle for this wonderful...
I could keep going for hours and hours
but I think that in the the
value of everybody's time
we should wrap up a
formal conversation now.
And I look forward to being in touch
with you professor Ay over
as the project unfolds
and we start actually...
We are hoping,
so Kyle is also part of our
sort of core team of people.
So the first set of activities
we have for this project
is a colloquium series
to really understand
different perspectives
and how people are thinking
and of course that we
are hoping in the future
to actually come up with
ways to formally understand,
to dive into the research
a little bit more
and maybe come up with new
creative ways of thinking
that might benefit from
across disciplinary learning
and sort of fertilizing
various methodologies.
So this was really, really fun and useful.
Thank you both and have
a wonderful weekend.
- Thank you so much.
And thank you Kyle for this
great introduction today.
(Kyle laughs)
- Yeah, no, that's great.
Yeah, I like having it start off
with something grounded
as well though (laughs).
- Kyle, we loved your slides
so if you don't mind sharing
them that would be great.
We'll just put them up.
Yeah, that'd be great.
- Yeah.
- And thank you everyone for attending.
So I want to say thanks
to the participants
and to Ty for helping
pull everything together
and to Guy for smoothly
managing the recordings.
Thanks everyone.
- Bye.
- Take care.